GOOD MORNING --
THIS RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH
IS HEREBY CALLED OR PLEASE
BE ADVISED ON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING INFORMATION FOR
SIX DAYS AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED AMERICA SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLING
AIR CUNNINGHAM CARILLO DAVE
FLORA GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE
HERE QUIRK SILVA HERE RAMOS
HERE PREVIOUS YEAR WORKS HERE
COR MAY HAVE A QUORUM AND WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
MOTION GROUP SESSIONS AND --
MOVE ON FROM SANTA MONICA FOR
-- KIND OF SUBTERFUGE CALLED
ONLY ONLINE COOLEY I'D
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO DE FLORA
FLORA I AGREE SENATE PERSON
I KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE
I'M QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I
RAMOS FOR ALMOST I READ THIS
REAVIS ILEX HIGH WEBSITES
MUST PASS THE MOTIONS PASS AND
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
THIS RULES BY THINKING WE WERE